um let's see why don't we go next
to uh why don't we go to amugo
from florida
hey david can you hear me yes i can well
it was good talking to you again i
remember we talked during the uh
georgia runoffs indeed yeah
um i guess mine is a question slash a
rant
like i'm just listening to um these
republicans and how they're talking
about oh we can't impeach the president
a former president now we should move on
this unity thing to keep talking
it's honestly driving me crazy because
it's like
you just saw what the president did he
incited an insurrection
democrats saying hey let's hold him
accountable and the republicans are
going
well we need unity you know we don't
it's already divided as it is and it's
like
it it just it's blowing my mind how
they're this man
even though he's not in office and just
yeah it's a terrible argument i mean one
i saw rand paul earlier this week say on
tv
you can't impeach a president who's no
longer in office
that's not only untrue but remember
trump was impeached while he was in
office the impeachment is what happens
in the house what happens in the senate
is the trial and either an acquittal or
or a conviction so
these are a combination of opportunists
and propagandists and people who
don't actually even have any interest in
sticking to the principles they claim to
hold very dear
and my approach is increasingly the
bernie approach
bernie said over the weekend listen
anything we can do via budget
reconciliation without a single
republican
if we determine we should do it and it's
good for the country we're going to do
it
uh we're not going to find 17
republicans to convict donald trump
okay well then then that then they won't
but that'll be them on record and we're
going to go through the tri
i just think we they're they are so
disingenuous with
when they want unity and when they don't
and when obstruction is acceptable
just get around them any way that you
can
yeah like i like i feel it with like the
left and the democrats i feel like our
issues are you know policy like we're
trying to say hey democrats push for 15
minimum wage push for universal health
care push for
efforts on climate change i feel like
the right is doing
you know who's more sycophantic to trump
like right um kyle kolinsky said this
bet
i don't know if he reported it or
something but he said that on the day
fox news called the election for joe
biden like
pretty much the majority of the fox news
viewers just fled fox news and went to
newsmax one american news their safe
space
yeah it's not it's not the majority it's
not the majority fox has seen a downtick
but you know the majority means over 50
percent
but i think you know the proof is in the
following
look at the people that just got
themselves elected most prominently
riding on the trump wave madison
hawthorne marjorie taylor green
lauren bobert and those types what what
is the big policy that they care about
what are their big policy positions
it's about owning the libs and riding
the trump wave and saying
we're not going to be cause communist
and social
it's completely vapid yeah
um one more thing before i let you go um
i don't do you know who brian
is by any chance did you say brian tyler
cohen
yeah yes i do i do yeah so him and tommy
lahren on the issue as they did a debate
before the i think was before after that
i think was after the election
and the the moderator asks oh if
democrats control the senate
um what's going to happen yes brian
tyler cohen this and how cohen said
oh fifty dollar minimum wage um access
to health care
climate change listed a bunch of things
i'm like oh that sounds really good
then he goes to tommy larry and goes oh
if the republicans control the senate
what's going to happen and she just said
stop socialism
that's like stop social yeah yeah i mean
there are other republicans who would
have other answers but that is that is
the epitome of
of what's going on right now politically
it's just unreal
anyway uh thank you appreciate i kind of
want to get that off my chest
appreciate it all right thanks amugo
amugo from florida let's take a quick
break if you're holding to talk to me
please don't hang up
because we're going to go right back to
the phones momentarily
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks s h masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covet 19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks
and shipping is free on orders over a
hundred and fifty dollars
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
the link is under this video and you can
save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david